[Music]
all right so yes I am here to talk to
you today
I had instructions to talk a little tiny
bit about our business model since it's
unusual but also I'm gonna be talking
about how to hack stuff with chat
thoughts and when I say hack stuff
that's what exactly what I mean
I am a ethical hacker a computer hacker
and I have a security company called
radically open security so uh but first
I'm going to talk a little bit about
radically open security we are a
not-for-profit computer security
consultancy company yeah so what that
means is we are something called a
fiscal fundraising institution in Dutch
it's called a fiscal Flammarion Stelling
for the NL net foundation okay now this
is actually a business model that came
from the Dutch churches churches
sometimes want to be able to do some
kind of commercial activity and then
they want to get the money back to the
church again okay so basically an
example of this is the language
institute regina coeli
otherwise known as the gnomon fund v so
the nuns of this little village called
food the nuns started this language
institute
it's an independently operating a
language institute of quite good quality
i might add and then when profits are
made they go basically at least 90% back
to the nuns
so we basically stole this well this uh
construction and we decided that we were
going to make our church and Elnett
those of you who are not familiar with
uh Nelnet it is a foundation and on be
staffing that has for at least twenty
years given money away to open-source to
academic research to basically digital
rights projects and basically anything
for a better internet why did i set up a
nonprofit security consultancy company
quite frankly it's because i was a bit
horrified at how commercial the security
consultancy industry had become I had a
period of time where I used to work on
the c-cert team for ING Bank I dealt
with a number of these consultancy
companies they came in they acted like
black boxes they were like security is
hard stand back we are going to solve
everything for you and give you a report
and a huge bill so and I was just like
you know if you guys are so leet then
you know there's a ton I can learn from
you so you know do you mind you know if
I watch along with what you're doing and
they were like no but really security is
hard and I was like okay you know I used
to be an assistant professor of computer
science at the Frey University I'd
specialized in computer security try me
you know but they threw away back
history logging they worked in screen
and forgot to turn on logging even
though I reminded them to do it 10 times
eventually I just physically stood there
and watched over their shoulders because
that way they couldn't get rid of me you
know and I saw that of course of course
that they were using the same
open-source tools as everyone else
surprised so you know I basically was a
bit disgruntled by this I asked around
hey you know other companies governments
organizations whoever are you happy with
this the black box behavior and
everybody was like universally like well
no but what's the alternative
okay and at the same time the hacker
community was also extremely unhappy
with the you know with the choice of
employers you know either you work for
big accountancy firms or for people
working with a secret intelligence
agency so you know take your pick so
basically I figured you know what I
think there's a hole in the market so
four years ago I left to found radically
open security so we are in many ways
extremely strange as a company not just
because we're nonprofit but also because
we are extremely modern we're completely
online we have no office yeah I mean of
course on some days when I see like the
pretty view out of the booking office
maybe yeah but I wonder what I might be
missing but
you know but the truth is we have a
globally distributed staff so I've got
like three pen testers in Australia I've
got you know a few more in India I've
got some in Latin America I've got them
spread throughout Europe you know so
then in the office doesn't really make
sense you know so we work online in chat
rooms okay so how many people here use
slack or something like it
okay that's almost everybody so we don't
use slack just because it's a cloud
service and we pen we hack people's
stuff so you know and it's as the
t-shirt says you know there is no cloud
there's just other people's computers so
instead we use this thing called rocket
chat who here has ever heard of rocket
Jets okay fewer hands so rocket jet is
an open-source self hosted slack clone
okay
matter most is also very similar who
here uses matter most anybody no okay
the nice thing about matter most is that
it's bundled with github but but we use
rocket chat and it's great I mean it's
basically just like slack except we have
governance over our own data you know on
top of that it's also frees and freedom
it's also free as in beer which you know
who doesn't love that so okay you know
it also has all the different slack
integrations which are super useful so
just saying you guys might want to check
out rocket chat alright so uh yeah so we
also are a collective of freelancers
okay so my entire company is a
collective of freelancers and SMEs ok so
basically my company has one employee
that's me I would I would be freelance
too but that's actually not allowed by
the by the Chamber of Commerce the
director actually has to be internal so
but everybody else is either freelance
or an SME and we've got 35 people that
we're collaborating with so the funny
thing is we're actually creating an
organization out of moveable parts you
know which also again makes us in
Stream Li unusual organization you know
and because everyone is freelance it
means they're also only part-time so all
of them have their own gigs going on
they have their own companies they have
their own independent customers but they
do come to us to collaborate you know
when there's stuff that needs to be done
and we basically just set it up as
win-win but of course it's kind of fun
is it fuzzy in our head then you know
what is our organization actually
because if people say to me oh yeah this
person in your project management team
does he work for radically open security
well yes he does but then again also he
sort of doesn't you know but but sharing
is the new owning you know and it works
that way with companies - and how do we
organize all of this we also use this
management methodology that is quite
excellent that is called holacracy I
believe that booking as far as I know is
also doing trials with this we're also
working with organisation builders I'm
pretty sure that the I think that you
guys are too so but as far as I know but
in either case we are super happy with
it and the way that that's organized is
we have several different circles with
different role descriptions and then
people can basically assume as many or
as few roles as they want which allows
people to kind of swap in we're a few
different hats and then swap out and
it's actually a really fun occasionally
it's a headache I'll be honest but like
you know because it means you can't
really rely on people being there but
then again it also allows you to build a
really resilient organisation where
people can come and go and it reduces
boss factors so anyway but because we
have this highly unusual environment for
our company and this highly unusual
structure it requires that we set things
up in a certain way so that's also
partly what my talk is going to be about
today now coming back to the actual
topic of my talk which is chat ups so
but what is chat ups who here actually
knows what chat ops is oh my gosh almost
no hands
okay so chat ops is basically making use
of chat thoughts to turn your chat room
into a command line okay
and then using that chat room as the
command and control center of your
operations so chat ops is a concept that
we gratuitously stole from the company
github we all love gift github the night
the interesting thing about github as
they also are highly distributed and
online so I believe they have an office
in the Bay Area but they also have staff
members all over the world okay so the
chatroom at that point becomes your
office so github created this
open-source chat BOTS called Hugh bot
okay and Hugh bought again it's open
source so anybody can install this and
play around with it but what they did is
github used the chat bot as sort of the
the command and control center for their
DevOps so you know I saw the lights
about three years ago I think at the dev
ops days here in Amsterdam and Paco said
this Viper and there was a guy from
github who was giving a talk and he was
basically saying look this is how we can
deploy a new server you know Hugh bought
you know I don't know exactly what it
was but you know deploy server and then
you know the server was deployed and
then the EULA said now I'd like to see
some statistics about our up time so
then Hugh bought you know show
statistics on you know whatever it was
statistics and I was like wow this is
really cool and then people were able to
intersperse conversations in between you
know performing the actual operational
operational operations so and this was
actually really great because if you
have a distributed team this makes the
work that they're doing visible to
everyone and allows you really to
coordinate and to discuss so I saw this
and I said oh my gosh
this would be incredible for penetration
testing so so penetration testing for
those of you who do not know what that
means it means hacking stuff so
radically open security is a company of
ethical hackers so we break things we
break people software we break people's
networks we break people's infra we
break people's you know embedded systems
we break people's crypto you name it we
break it yeah it's a fun job
if it's easier to break it than to build
it right by the way but yes so so
basically I figured you know I think we
could really use this chat bot in our
penetration testing process so we ran
home and we set up raka chats and and
our own version of Hugh bot and we
basically said you know what kinds of
commands could we possibly perform you
know with with the chat bot might be
this slide is a bit old and it needs to
be replaced him but actually is ancient
but but in either case but it gives an
idea though of what you can do it's
really a combination of stuff that's
useful and stuff that's completely
useless so for example you can have a I
mean as you were able to concede in the
last slide there's this comment a
command here called raw spot hug me so I
type in raw spot hug me and then you get
a picture of a pug it's completely
useless it's it's good for culture
though but you know but there's also
other actually useful things that we can
do with it though I mean for example we
can use go you know raw spot md5 and be
able to calculate a hash for something
we can also go raw spot and map you know
who won 27001 you know and perform an
nmap scan on our internal network you
know we've actually got a number of our
hacking tools actually set up so that we
can invoke them via the chat we've also
got exactly the same thing with our
report and documentary Asian structure
and ultimately with our almost our
entire workflow so uh like every company
in the universe our techies hate
documentation you know but you know if
your pen testers it's a necessary evil
you know customers want their pen test
reports it's just you know facts
inconvenient facts of life so like every
other pen test company in the universe
we created our automated system to try
and take some of the pain out of this so
we have xml templates and basically what
you can do is you can fill in
about an a force worth of XML and then
you can basically compile it and then
you can get quotations for example you
can also do the same with penetration
test reports well this is the expanded
form but if you compile it you get
something that looks kind of like this
which basically looks like every pen
testing report in the universe we
created a system called pen text for
this pen text so we open-source this so
if any of you any of you want to do
internal scanning I want to produce your
own pretty reports it's open source so
feel free to steal it in fact we even
made an a wasp project out of it how
many of you here are familiar with a
wasp okay
ever heard of the OWASP top 10 if not
please research it this is important
secure coding but anyhow so yeah so we
have you know an OAuth is basically the
umbrella organization for web
penetration testers aka the kinds of
people who are hacking the stuff that
you guys are writing so you should know
about OWASP that wasp top ten there's a
bunch of open source tools available
there that you can use so anyhow but the
nice thing is we can actually invoke all
of this stuff then via the chat so you
can see an example here that we I can go
for example raw spots quick scope and in
this case it's for a quotation so oh F F
is for oferta I'm sorry we're a Dutch
company you know but so fair it's a
Melanie demo and then what happens is
raw spot at that point converts that a
for is worth of XML into a larger more
expansive XML then I go raw spot build
quote a fair - Melanie demo and what you
can see is raw spot at this point is
actually invoking now the backend tool
chain that we have set up on the server
for compiling XML documents into PDF at
that point it says ok I have now built
this PDF it's also a password protected
so here's the password for this PDF that
I just built click here to open it
now what's great about this what's great
about this is I can onboard new staff
members into my company and they can
basically use our entire XML to PDF tool
chain without having to install a single
thing on their client device what you're
doing is you're actually taking a web
browser and basically turning that web
browser basically into the intern into
the interface to the actual working
environment the operational environment
of your company so what this means is
that our you know our environment our
chat ops environment of course is you
know maintained by system administrators
and DevOps folks on our back-end servers
but once that's set up you know people
can then once they get through a couple
layers of s authentication of course but
you know once they then get through that
they can use our the entire power of our
entire hacking environment without
having to install anything so that end
maps can I'm like with you know Ross bot
nmap you know I can launch it basically
from my laptop in a coffee shop I can
launch it from my cell phone
you know while sitting on it on a bus
you know I mean this is actually the
really great thing you know and and
again we can basically bring new people
in we don't have to worry about
administering you know their client
devices I mean there's a few basic OPSEC
rules they should follow like you know
please work in VMs and you know that
kind of thing but at the same time you
know it really centralizes you know all
of these these efforts and it's also
incredibly powerful it also means that
if we make updates to the software that
we're using for our operations you know
we don't have to have to actually have
to deploy it you know to everybody you
know we just make one change on that
back-end server and then everybody then
at that point has that upgrade so that's
really nice oh another really nice thing
that we do by the way with this chat ops
stuff and so I told you guys that story
about how I was standing and watching
over the kunia the the security
consultants shoulder right because I
wanted to know what was going on so we
created
this thing called peek over our shoulder
what that means is we invite customers
to join us in our chat rooms so they can
watch us hacking their stuff in real
time you know during the course of an
engagement
so basically when hackers ethical
hackers are having conversations talking
about hacking their stuff they can
eavesdrop and listen to those
conversations every word of them because
our chat room is our office so because
our chat room is our primary means of
communications it means that the
customer who then can be added into the
chat room hears everything that we've
said so that actually you know basically
takes that black box and completely
explodes it inside out into something
that is so transparent you know it's
almost annoying but the other thing that
we do is we make use of this chat bot so
Ross bot which is what it's called of
course cuz we're radically open security
it also is hooked up to our git lab
repository so we also make use of gitlab
another good Amsterdam company and we
use basically that for of course you
know way to use get for of course you
know document management and also
merging and collaboration and all that
kind of good stuff
so during penetration tests we use get
lab issues for writing up notes and
comments and you know findings and that
kind of thing and then we have for
example if you want to push some scan
results we can just you know do a push
to that get lab repo now we have used
the slack integrations between get lab
and raqqa chat so at that point the rot
the chat bot makes step-by-step
announcements that you know this pen
tester just made this comment at this
time stamp click here for more
information
okay so literally the customer who is
just sitting there in the channel is
getting updates you know several times
an hour that the pen tester just did
this the pen tester just did that the
pen testers
that do you know how much extra work it
takes for the pen tester to do this zero
so we literally can make our entire
process completely transparent to the
customer with no extra work and by the
way with this layer of this level of
transparency it leads to happy customers
you know the other nice thing is a lot
of people you say yeah but isn't it
really annoying having the customer in
your chat room well actually no it's not
it's not annoying at all and for several
reasons one reason is because you know
if we are performing a penetration test
we are a third party so we're basically
coming in without prior knowledge of
their system nobody knows the customers
systems and code and infrastructure as
well as the customer themselves so when
we have the customer in our chat room it
is like having an Oracle in our chat
room so if we get stuck you know or if
we have questions or if we need a server
rebooted or whatever you know we
literally have the developers of that
software that we're testing or the SIS
admin's or whoever else in the channel
with us so we can just ask you know hey
what does this code pass actually do
well what does it how about this
function you know by the way you know
did you guys use a strong password here
you know we're wondering if it's worth
the time you know to run the cracker etc
so you know and this is really handy
because it means you know instead of
just hitting our head up against brick
walls and then having to figure it out
sort of by ourselves I mean we've got
you know the people who have actually
developed it here saying oh no worries
you know you do this and you do that and
it makes us twice as efficient at the
end of the day and being able to pen
test because we don't waste time on
stupid things the other nice thing about
giving radical transparency to your
working process used to your customers
it's because let's face it occasionally
things go wrong right you know it could
very well be that maybe we accidentally
at the beginning of the work at the
beginning of the engagement for example
under scope the work so we thought oh
you know we could perhaps perform this
pen test in three weeks but now
you know we're at one and a half weeks
and oh it actually turns out that we
might have underestimated how big a kid
or how complex are you know that the
second half was so because the customer
is there we can then say hey you know
dear customer you know we are now at the
50% point of our engagement we've used
in ours there's you know an hours left
and you know I mean it looks like we
might have grossly you know made an
incorrect guess about how long this
would take we would like your input
about what is the most important so we
can actually make sure that in the time
remaining we can actually prioritize the
most important things for you and then
we can make sure the slightly less
important things then get written up as
being future work now this actually
makes customers really happy you know
because it makes sure that their
priorities getnet
you know and it also prevents those
kinds of nasty surprises and if anything
there's anything that customers don't
like it's it's nasty surprises
you know but because you have this level
of deep communications going on with
them all the time and they feel like
they have knobs to turn and buttons that
they can push you know it actually
ultimately if they see something a
problem coming they see it coming from a
mile away you know which means that they
actually have input then in helping you
to fix it by the way what I'm saying
right now is not just applicable to pen
testing this might also be applicable to
software development this could also be
applicable to data analysis I mean
basically anyone who's dealing with
customers you know take a moment to
pause and reflect on how actually having
your customers in the chat room with
with you might make you have made your
own customers happier so anyhow but
moving on so get lab is another part of
sort of the I don't know holy trilogy of
open-source software that we that we use
we also make use of the can board open
source software for our project
management although I have to say we're
migrating over to using get lab for that
now
but well for using their Ken board but
so you know the repos look as reposed
would look um you know but all manners
of tooling you know we can basically
hook up via this chat up stuff so for
example we created an open-source
passive scanning tool so this takes
output from show Dom from census you
know scans i/o from basically passive
scanning sources that we would perhaps
run at the start of a pen test we've
open-sourced this by the way check out
our github repository it's actually our
policy with radically open security to
open source all of the tools and
frameworks and documentation and
trainings and absolutely everything that
the company does except for personal
data because we love the gdpr
and of course also a customer pen test
data cuz that's confidential but yeah
but everything else that can be
sanitized we do release as open source
but we can then take this passive
vulnerability scanning tool and then
again be able to invoke this via the
chat cool right something else that we
can do is something called red blue pen
testing so what we do is we take the
penetration test of a customer and we
can take we basically gamify their pen
test okay so let's say that we have a
dozen developer assisted men's dev ops
folks now let's say we take this does
and then we split them into two teams it
could be a red team in a blue team it
could be a red team in a red team
depends on how they want to set it up
but we take each team and each team is
guided by one of our professional pen
testers what we then do is we give them
a set period of time let's say a few
days and they compete to hack their own
stuff okay so basically this is actually
a really great way to do it because
developers know their own products
inside and outs and they've also got
their own ideas about what might be a
little bit wonky you know with that
product and if the developers get stuck
of course our professional pen testers
are there to be like hey
if you thought about that you ever used
this tool why don't you try this you
know just to you know provide enough
hints it's keep things going the really
nice thing about this is basically for
the price of two full-time pen testers
you know for a few days you know
probably plus a couple extra days to
clean up the mess that you guys make out
of the reporting but that aside you know
basically what you get is actually a
training exercise for a dozen people and
and are an incredibly thorough pen test
report because you basically just had a
dozen mines and a dozen eyeballs looking
at that code but the best thing about
this is that it eliminates the the
defensive nosov the developers you know
for the against the pen testing process
because if you come in as a third party
and you say your stuff is broken then
you know what people are gonna say
they're gonna say no it's not but it's
supposed to be that way it's a feature
but this manager signed off on it so
it's okay yeah but you have to be super
geniuses you know to be able to do this
stuff and you know but the thing is the
second that they hack it themselves
they're like I did this you know and
they are proud that they hacked their
own stuff you know and because it's
actually turned into a competition and
they're competing against one another
they get into it you know so they
completely step out of the role of being
a developer for a few days and then they
step into the into the shoes of being a
hacker and then that is completely where
what they throw themselves into and the
number one comment that we get at the
end of these red-blue exercises is and I
quote I will never think about code the
same way again and that is what it's all
about you know because coming in also as
a pen test company and giving a pen test
and just having people fix it you know
it's like you know it's like the old
parable with like you know teaching to
fish versus throwing fish you can throw
fish but at the end of the day sick
is not a pen test report that's
basically just a one time snapshot but
security is a mindset security is a
process security is an attitude and and
that is not something that can be
contained just in the seaso office or in
the security officers the real place
where that's mindset needs to be is in
the developers you know and I think that
having developer step out of their own
shoes to perform that pen test for a few
days really works wonders and actually
doing something meaningful to improve
your organizational security anyway but
coming back to chat ups the only reason
why this gamification is possible is
because of chat ops you can see here for
example that we created a scoreboard
application in our chat so you can see
for example we're having conversations
right now so you can see a point for
blue for finding missing input
validation and then I use a command
called good job blue when I type in good
job blue then Ross spot says incremented
blue 24 points and it shows a
motivational image geeks like that so
you know and that you know is great you
know and again because these people can
work in this chat environment you know
that's how we make this kind of stuff
possible and I don't think we could even
do this without chat ops to be honest
but what else can you do with chat ops
so basically any of our hacking and
scanning you know for the most part I
would say can probably be automated and
integrated into chat ups so things like
nmap skins for enumerated infrastructure
web application scanning tools like w3
AF a sequel map for exploiting databases
Hydra for brute forcing passwords etc I
mean there's always going to be some
small number of things that are hard to
do via chat ups I mean anything we have
to point-and-click is a little bit hard
so for example burp suite is you know
hard to integrate into chat ups but a
lot of tools though you can
reconnaissance so who is you know isn't
one example you know Google queries or
DuckDuckGo or
let me DuckDuckGo that for you yes we
actually have that so you know our
passive scanning tool that we created
etc also other kinds of things for
exploitation like hash cracking oh my
god this is the best thing in the world
we have rainbow tables okay we have
rainbow tables and you can invoke them
via our chat opps so I can be sitting in
a bus on my cell phone and I can crack
somebody's password using rainbow tables
from my cell phone how cool is that
seriously anyway so anyway I'm geeking
out here you know we've also got a open
source spearfishing suite and this is
also so much fun so what we do is we've
got a set of chat ops tools so what we
can do is first of course with fishing
you have to create a pretext so we can
basically use a chat ops command to
scrape a web page and then instrument
that web page with links that then go
basically to our landing page on our web
server what we then can do is put
together a distribution list using
gitlab of email addresses and we can
that we have another chat ops command
then to actually send the emails to the
fishing targets now this is where the
fun starts so you know the the the
fishing mail now has been launched and
we again are using these rocket chat
integrations so every time one of the
targets clicks on that fishing mail it
injects in real time an announcement
into the chatroom the appropriate
chatroom that says this email recipient
just clicked on this pretext name at
this timestamp so mind you the security
officers from that company are sitting
in the channel watching their own
company get fished you know what another
thing also is one of the fishing tests I
think we did about a month ago we also
had a forum so we were actually
harvesting credentials at the same time
so people could fill in the form so you
know username password
you know and we fished about 150 people
about 30 people filled in that form
you know but at a certain point one of
the coders saw that the domain name
wasn't correctly entirely correct so at
that point the developer started playing
with the form so we started seeing
strange things coming in so for example
use her name
nice try [ __ ] password you know
something else
username woohoo password
a sequel injection that was my favorite
no it didn't work but he got points for
trying yeah
of course at the end of the day we were
also asking questions like gee is he
doing this from a sandboxed environment
you know but at a certain point when
that was over them you know the security
officers were like man that was
entertaining thank you whoo we're going
for lunch now you know but again this is
actually the really nice stuff about
using chat ops okay you know it makes
all of this stuff visible and I couldn't
even think of a way to be able to offer
this kind of service if you weren't
using some kind of chat environment with
a bot so all right so we can do a lot of
other kinds of things related more
related to running a company generically
you know with chat ops so for example
project management so like every other
company in the universe we also have
project management we use Ken Kanban
basically for this and a can board for
well tracking our workflow basically we
have commands that for example allow us
to view the can board you know from the
chat room so we can basically be able to
say you know I would like to know you
know the status for example of this
project and then we can retrieve that
information from the can board and
display it we can also update that
information from the chat room and
what's even better is we've actually
found ways to update project management
information as a side effect of doing
other things
so let me explain we've got this thing
called the shipit' squirrel who here
knows what the shipit' squirrel is oh
god ok you guys are missing out so this
is some more geek culture for you so
there is this thing in slack called the
shipit squirrel
so you basically go you know you bought
ship it and it gives you a picture of a
squirrel it's cool no but look I mean
it's meant as a way of celebrating the
fact that you just shipped something you
know because we like shipping right we
all like shipping so you know and for
you guys at shipping code for us at
shipping like a pen test report or a
quotation or whatever you know but in
either case you know we need to
celebrate the good stuff but the really
nice thing is when somebody goes Ross
pot ship it they get the squirrel you
know we're all happy but it also takes
that item on the can board and it moves
it to done yes so we're actually getting
lazy
you know pen testers to actually update
project management information so you
know this is the kind of stuff again
that you can sort of do from the chat um
we've got another mechanism that we call
get notes and what this is is we
actually built our own kind of support
desk mechanism for emails so what it is
is we for example you know how if you
use like Zendesk and those kinds of
solutions you basically get this magic
email address and then you know as long
as you carbon copy you're blind carbon
copy this particular magic email address
then you're how do I say your support
desk system then tracks the whole email
threads and that kind of thing so we
basically built that system ourselves
except for the fact that if this magic
email address is carbon copied or blind
carbon copied
first of all it injects a copy of that
in to get gitlab but the second thing
that that does is it again it uses the
rocket jet integrations so it actually
injects a message into the chatroom that
basically says this sender just sent an
email with this subject at this
timestamp click here to read it so we
actually no in real time in the chat
rooms when there's new you know
information relating to a particular
engagement you know and we basically use
these triads which basically are sort of
like you know get lab repo chat room
name and can board item you know I
basically tie these together to make
sure that the appropriate things always
get sent to the appropriate places now
the really nice thing about this is for
example let's say we're working with a
multinational or a really large customer
and we're basically doing multiple
projects with different business units
for them
okay now the security officers want to
know what communications were having
with our business units you know they
want us to keep them you know on top of
things
so what we do is we add the security
officers into all of their their chat
rooms that are related to them we
actually even can do this automatically
that if we create a new you know chat
room for this particular customer we can
automatically add you know the people
from you know the list of you know
security officers from that company and
then what happens is then when we use
this magic email address they get these
they also see these chatroom
announcements you know from the bot
which basically means that they can then
click on it and with zero extra effort
we have now looped in the customer on
all of our correspondence with all of
their business units and it costs us
almost zero extra work good stuff
another thing that we have implemented
with chat UPS is for example what we
call raw spot charge so this is
basically how we track billable hours so
like every consultancy company we have
to track billable hours of course this
also is the bane of our existence
because you know we all hate
administration we're geeks we do but
we've made it as painless as possible
because basically what you can do is you
just in the particular chat room where
you're working you can say raw spot
charge the number of hours description
and then Ross watt says thank you name
of pen tester you just charged n hours
you have now used M hours out of the
allocated X hours for this particular
engagement you are now 30 / 7 percent
of the way through this engagement with
a little progress bar this is nice
because it allows us really I mean yes
it makes a declaring our is easy but it
also gives people step by step and
always a picture of how far along are we
and how much time do we have left the
even better part about it is because the
customers are in the chat room while
this is happening they see exactly where
their money is going you know because
with consultancy time is money that's
how it is
so basically when we put a certain
number of billable hours into this it
means they can see in excruciating
detail exactly where that time is going
and you know what they love it so this
is actually really nice other in front
related things access control so we use
role based access control primarily
because we for example don't want our
customers launching scans against other
people you know we also don't want them
being able to read you know the contents
of our can board for example you know
that kind of stuff so we do have role
based access control that is tied in
with the chat room I have to say that
the role based access control as we have
it set up then is tied in with our I
mentioned holacracy earlier so basically
with how we have circles and how we have
roles basically that actually fits in
really really well with the role based
access control that we use on the
emphasize error logging okay so we all
need to debug stuff you know one of the
things about chat chat ops that you know
can't isn't always a good thing is it
means that our chat environment is
production okay in every sense of the
word if our chat environment and our
chat ops environment goes offline our
entire company goes down you know and
that way it's actually not probably not
too dissimilar from you know booking
comm and you know some of those other
companies you know if you're in for goes
offline and your company is probably
offline too but for us what that means
is radically open security is actually
turning into a DevOps company you know
and there's not a lot of security
companies that will say that but it
really is true because we can't have
outages it is disruptive to the entire
company
so in that sense you know we have been
having a massive mega refactoring in the
last number of months we've been adding
unit testing to absolutely everything
you know we have been adding continuous
integration continuous deployment
we've been docker izing you know certain
things so we can basically be able to
automatically create you know properly
configured environments and then be able
to destroy them afterwards
you know and this also for operational
security and also GDP our concerns is
also really important because you know
we shouldn't have old data hanging
around for a really long time just
there's many different ways in which
that's bad but back to debugging so we
have chat rooms that do absolutely
nothing else except display error logs
and this is really great because then
the developers in my infra team can see
all of the error logging for the code
that they're writing without needing
shell on the server you know for
security that is just awesome
so you know we've got an error log
channel we've got debug logs channels
you can basically create as many
channels as you want for the different
kinds of logging you don't add everybody
to those channels they're only
interesting to a certain subset of
people but this is great we also created
a help menu system that resembles man
pages um you know just because well you
know when you start having so many chat
ups commands you need some way of being
able to keep them organized and so
people know what the syntax are are of
all of them etc so we basically created
a kind of an interactive man pagers kind
of style thing you know that we used to
keep the chat ops commands organized you
know and the future as I see it are
things like AI chat BOTS you know I
think the first workshop on day one you
know was one of the workshops was
talking about how to make interactive
intelligent chat BOTS with natural
language processing I just want to say
that I think that the potential for this
kind of thing is enormous you know since
you guys are data scientists just let me
say really quickly if you guys know
anybody who is interested in working on
this particular thing and or if you know
any master students looking for thesis
projects you know I
we would actually be a really great
applied place to do such a thing because
we have a super need for it you know and
I think we could use these AI chat BOTS
for things like answering frequently
asked questions we can use it for
onboarding people we could use it for
customer satisfaction surveys we could
use it for staff satisfaction surveys
and the really nice thing about the chat
UPS is you know especially with surveys
let's face it
surveys are annoying you know I get
surveys all the time in the email and
you know what I do I throw them away I
ignore them because they're annoying you
know but if you do a survey in the chat
you can use the chat bot to enforce the
discipline of doing the asking because
of course you know oftentimes we forget
but if the customer gives a question or
an answer that you weren't expecting
there's humans in the room which means
then that the human can actually take
over the conversation you know which
then again gives it the personal touch
if you know which makes sure that it
actually isn't annoying
so I think there's so much that we can
do with chat bots also in terms of
hacking so anyway if anybody is
interested talk to me please
so okay a lot about us I think is very
weird but weird is actually sort of
almost kind of the same thing as really
innovative so okay you know we have won
a lot of awards
you know both for our business model as
well as for the way that we work so we
for example the Dutch Chamber of
Commerce called radically open security
the fiftieth most innovative SME in the
Netherlands you know in 2016 I am super
proud of that another thing also we have
won you know Innovation Awards for some
of our not-for-profit projects that
we've done I've had no time today to
talk about them but we do a number of
nonprofit projects because again we're a
non-profit company so we can afford to
be able to do this for cost price for
NGOs and civil society groups so we had
this med aid kit which is a Wi-Fi
completely open-source Wi-Fi tour an
open VPN router for 25 euros that we
built together with Free Press unlimited
over on the v-belt struct and we won
basically the Internet freedom festival
to showcase Award for that also the ice
Hawk ml in
Internet innovation award we've won
words for research one of our hackers
want an award of black hats for most
innovative research the pony award which
is no small deal if you guys know
anything about security conferences um
you know we want entrepreneurship awards
things like the sprout challenge or 50
you know and well most recently CIO
magazine actually called me the most
innovative IT leader in the Netherlands
for 2017 so but look I don't think it's
about me it's more about what we're
trying to do number one the nonprofit
company stop and think about how you
guys could create nonprofit companies in
your own area so my new side project
that I'm currently starting is something
called nonprofit ventures so what it is
we're actually building a non-profit
incubator to help create more nonprofit
companies okay so this is up-and-coming
I think it's a new kind of social
enterprise that I think we can apply
think about it this way
business as a tool for positive impact
business as a tool for activism business
as an creative artform business as a
form of self-expression you know people
don't think about business this way but
I think that we should because if enough
people created not-for-profit social
enterprises I think that the world would
be a lot better place than it currently
is so I think that's one thing the other
thing of course that's innovative about
us is the openness and transparency so
please try and think about how you can
take some of these principles and
integrate them into your own
organizations there's a lot of good
ideas and also all of our software is
open source and free freely available
for anyone so thank you so much for your
time and attention I'm happy to take any
questions so thank you
[Applause]